[موسيقى]
يلا حيهم اتفهم يمكن عنوان الفيديو شوي
شاطح خاصه انه ما نشرنا شيء لنا تقريبا
ثلاث شهور لكنه منظمه اياها متابعين
البرنامج وقلت بخصص هالفيديو اللي بنشره
قبل ما ينشر الموسم باسبوع تقريبا للاجابه
على ابرز التساؤلات اللي يسالونا اياها
الناس بدايه خليني اتكلم عن ليش قطعنا
الفتره الماضيه كنا مثل ما تعرفون ننشر
بشكل اسبوعي ومعنا هالشي ممتاز جدا من
ناحيه المستمع يتعود انه كل اسبوع وفي نفس
اليوم تنزل حلقه جديده ويكون في محتوى
جديد الا انه تعبنا صراحه من ناحيه
الانتاج لانه حول هدفنا من اننا ننتج
المحتوى اللي فعلا نبغى ننتجه الى اننا
نحاول نلحق بس جدول الانتاج وننشر الحلقه
بموعدها فهالشي كان فيه تاثير على بعض
الحلقات من ناحيه الجوده وفضلنا ننتقل من
النشر الاسبوعي الى النشر بشكل مواسم
فبيكون في انقاط انقطاعات بسيطه ما بين
موسم وموسم ولكن اول ما يبدا نشر الموسم
يستمر نشر الموسم بشكل اسبوعي ونصمم
الموسم بشكل يعني راضيين عنه تماما ويكون
من ناحيه الضيوف من ناحيه القطاعات من
ناحيه احجام والضيوف
ونتاكد اننا نبغى وصلنا الارسال نوصلها
للمستمع فيها الحلقات جميعا بشكل متوازن و
جيد منكم مثلا مركزين على ثلاث حلقات فجاه
كلها شركه تقنيه ورا بعض بعدين ثلاث حلقات
كلها في قطاع المطاعم زي ما صار في فتره
من الفترات نخلي الموسم متوازن ويخدم يعني
اغلب المستمعين بمختلف اهتماماتهم
فبتلاحظون ان شاء الله من الاسبوع الجاي
مع بدايه نشر الموسم الجديد عده اختلافات
اولها هويه جديده للبرنامج وثاني شيء
بتلاحظون في توازن اكبر بين
ضيوف الحلقات وثالث شيء في اختلاف حتى في
الاماكن اللي نصور فيها بعض الضيوف نروح
لهم في مكاتبهم نصور هناك وبعضهم نصور
معاهم في اماكن خارجيه تكون يعني اماكن
حلوه للتصوير وفيها تغيير شوي سواء
للمشاهد او حتى لي انا بعدها ولا الضيف
الان ودي اجاوب على مجموعه اسئله تنطرح
علينا كثير وكلها تقريبا تخص الضيوف يمكن
ابرزها هل الضيوف او بعض الضيوف يدفع
مقابل الظهور في البرنامج ولا لا وهالشيء
ما يصير لسببين اول سبب انه يتعارض مع
سياسه ثمانيه وثاني سبب انه بياثر صراحه
على حياديه المحتوى وبحس كذا اني احاول
اضبط الضيف واحاول اطلعه بشكل جيد حتى
ضمنيا حتى لو الضيف ما طلب بس مساله مدافع
مساله غير مريحه واقول هالشي لاني اعرفها
من تجربه جربتها قبل ما انضم الى ثمانيه
انه كان في احد الضيوف البرنامج
صوتي فقط دفع للظهور لان ما كنت معطيه
اولويه صراحه
لكن اتفقت معاه انه خلاص ادفع مقابل
الظهور واعتب له اعتبره اعلان ومع ان
المحتوى كان فيه حياديه كبيره صراحه ما
كان في تسويق او شيء زي كذا لكن ما كان
الموضوع مريح ابدا بالنسبه لي من يوم
ثمانيه استحوذت البرنامج كانت واضحه
الضيوف ما يدفعون مقابل الظهور لكن في
الشركات ممكن ترى البرنامج وهذا الخط
يعتبر مستقل ولا يؤثر على حياته البرنامج
ولا على خط التحريري الى الانتاج بشكل عام
سؤال ثاني يتكرر عن ليش في بعض الضيوف
اللي تكرر الطلب عليهم
ما يطلعون في البرنامج وما نستضيفهم في
اكثر من سبب لعدم استضافه الضيوف في
البرنامج السبب الاول ان تضيف نفسه يكون
ما عنده رغبه في الظهور الاعلامي سبب اخر
ان الضيف يكون يفضل في لقاءاته الاعلاميه
انه يكون الجانب التسويقي فيها يطغى اكثر
على مشاركه الخبره والتجربه والفائده
فيطلع يتكلم عن ما ادري عن
البزنس عند رؤيه المستقبليه للقطاع عن
اشياء تسويقيه ومن حق الضيف طبعا انه
يختار اللقاءات الاعلاميه اللي تناسبه بس
هي تكون بالنهايه ما تناسب سوالف بزنس
لانه احنا مركزين على الضيوف اللي شاركوا
خبرتهم تجربتهم يشاركون الاشياء اللي فعلا
المجتمع اذا سمعها يقدر ياخذها ويطبق في
السوق لكن الاغلب الحمد لله ما نواجه
مشكله معاهم اذا كلمناهم الاستضافه بل على
العكس لاننا نحن نركز على الجانب التشغيلي
او على الخبره ونبعد عن كلام الحشو
والتسويق والكلام مكرر فيك ضيوف كثير
اطلعوا في البرنامج كان هذا اول ظهور
اعلامي لو هو ممكن حتى بعضهم كان الظهر
الاول والاخير بعدها ما طلعوا
مرتاحين يبغون يشاركون خبره يبغون يشاركون
معرفه ما يكونون يعني يكونون الناس ما
يرتاحون بسالفه النوم كذا يحطون في موقف
انه انت ما شاء الله شخص ناجح سولف لنا عن
كفاحك سولف لنا عن تعبك
فيرتاحون في الظهور في برنامجكم في
تجربتهم ولكن ايضا لان انا اركز على
الجانب التشغيلي وندخل في تفاصيل البزنس و
احيانا نقاشات حاميه في البرنامج يظهر
لبعض الضيوف المحتمل للبرنامج ان البرنامج
برنامج يمكن اثاره تحجير شيء زي كذا
يتخوفون من الظهور يقول خاف اطلع اقول شيء
بالغلط يسالني مشغول سؤال ام مشهور سؤال
يحشرني بسالفه واندم على الظهور تصير لي
مشاكل خاصه بعض الجهات الحكوميه اللي
تواصلنا معها في البرنامج كان عندهم شويه
تخوف من الظهور لهذا السبب لكن اللي يسويه
في سوالف بزنس لانه حريصين نوصل فعليا
تجربه الضيف للمستمع وما يهمنا موضوع
الاثاره وموضوع يعني المشاهدات او المرا
هذه كلها فنعرف مع الضيف قبل التصوير انه
نتاكد من المواضيع المحظوره اللي ما قدرت
ادخل فيها مثلا مشاكل مع ش بعض الاسئله
المفروض نتجنبها لانها قد تسبب مشكله بعض
الممارسات بعض الشركات عندهم الممارسات
غير قانونيه صراحه فيقولون الفتره هذه
قاعده نتكلم مع الجهه اللي تشرع هالموضوع
فلا نطرها الموضوع لمن نخلص معاهم
فنتاكد من الضيف انه ما راح نتطرق لاي
موضوع بسبب له مشكله بعد بعد الحلقه واذا
كان عنده تحفظات معينه ونعتقد ان التطرق
لهذه التحفظات يكون في فائده للمستمع
فاسال الضيف مثلا ما تبي تتكلم على
ايرادات اتفاهم هالشيء خايف من المنافس
يعرف او ايا كان لا تقولي ايراداتك كم
بالضبط خلنا نتكلم نقول اراده مثلا ما بين
كذا وكذا نقول ايراداتك اكثر من كذا
المعلومه اللي بيئه بالمجتمع يستفيد منها
ان هذا الشركه بهذا الحجم ما يهمني محاسب
قانوني ولا الهيئه الزكاه الدخل وراك فيه
كم بالضبط تدخل يهمني بس اني اوصل
المعلومه هذه
للمستمع ان اعتم النقاش في الحلقه غالبا
يكون الضيف حاول ينحرف شوي الى المسار
التسويقي فانا ارجعه ثاني مره الى مسار
التشغيلي من جديد ولا نركز على الفائده
نركز على التجربه ونتكلم اكثر عنها بعض
الضيوف حتى احيانا يغلط في الحلقه ويذكر
شيء المفروض ما يذكره حتى المجال ان الضيف
يتدارك الشيء هذا ويصححه لانه ما يغرط اي
احد في اي معلومه يقولها لكن يظل النقاش
بيريحيه وبعفويه نرتجل الاسئله طبعا مع
الضيوف نسولف معهم بشكل
مريح جدا والحمد لله يعني الاغلبيه العظمى
والضيوف بعد ظهور من البرنامج يتواصلون
معي يقول الحمد لله كان يعني ظهور جدا
ممتاز واستفادوا منه سواء في التوظيف في
توضيح فكره الشركه في حل بعض المشاكل
التشغيلين اللي يواجهونها فهذا الاثر اللي
اسعد صراحه انه يصير سواء عند المستمعين
اللي يتواصلون معنا بكثره يقولون يعني
شكرا انكم علمتونا وايش الشركه هذه تسوي
بالضبط قدرت تستفيد منها تقدر تستفيد منها
تاثير الشركه اذا تستفيد منها في معلومات
عامه حتى لو ما
وايضا على مستوى الضيوف اللي يستفيدوا
منها بشكل كبير انه طلعوا يتكلمون عن
مشاكلهم الحقيقيه وتجربتهم الحقيقيه وساحه
معين الموظفين المستثمرين الشركاء لايا
كان الجوانب اللي فادتهم او الاستفاده
منها من خلال ظهرهم اخر نقطه بخصوص الضيوف
انه ليش في برامج اخرى من ثمانيه
يستضيفون الضيوف قد يراها المجتمع انهم
انسب للظهور في سؤال لانهم رؤساء شركات
وناس يعملهم في هذا القطاع فعليا مجرد ان
الضيف رئيس شركه او احد التنفيذيين فيها
او مستثمر في السوق لا يعني انه بالضروره
لازم نستضيف في سؤال قد يظهر في فنجان
لانه بغطي مواضيع من جانب مختلف يناسب
فنجان اكثر او يظهر في سقراط بيغطي تجربته
او المضيع اللي بتكلم عنها تكون من جانب
مختلف يناسب خط سقراط فاحنا نركز فقط على
الزاويه اللي تهمنا اللي هي الجوانب
التشغيليه التحديات المشاكل هذه كلها اللي
في البزنس التجارب مشاركه الخبرات ذلك
وختاما شكرا لكم على مشاركتكم المستمره
للاقتراحات الاسئله
انتقادات المدح في ناس كثير حتى يساعدونا
نوصل لضيوف ما كنا نقدر نوصل لهم سابقا
شكرا لكم وسعيد جدا صراحه ان البرنامج هذا
قاعد يوصل لعدد الكبير من الناس يهمنا
بالدرجه الاولى للاثر اللي نتركه ويسعدني
صراحه دائما صادف ناس في اماكن عامه او في
المؤتمرات اللي يذكرون مدى استفادتهم من
البرنامج هالشي يسعدني جدا استفاده شخص
واحد تغنيني عن مئه الف مشاهده صراحه ان
شاء الله نكون دائما تحسن ظنكم ونشوفكم ان
شاء الله الاسبوع الجاي مع حلقه جديده من
سوالف بزنس
[موسيقى]